today we will be explaining all curses
in jiu jitsu kaizen we will start from
the weakest roppongi curse but in later
parts of the video we will cover much
stronger and more interesting curses
number 12. roppongi curse not long after
being accepted into tokyo jujutsu high
yuji idadori joined a team with megami
and a new student nobara while megami
recovered from his injuries inflicted
during his previous fight yuji and
nabarro were tasked by gojo with
clearing out an abandoned warehouse in
roppongi it was here that they
encountered a particularly nasty curse
that had taken a boy hostage this curse
was remarkable not for its strength but
for its cunning and intelligence it used
the boy as a shield and was willing to
kill the child to save itself and if not
for a timely surprise attack by yuji
this situation may have turned out far
worse number 11. a cult club curse the
first curse that yuji ever encountered
is the one that attacked his friends in
the occult club at his former school the
curse was at the school looking for one
of sukuna's fingers which are special
grade cursed objects that attract curses
this curse was physically strong and
smart enough to ambush megami when he
was not paying attention as megami gets
tossed around by the spirit yuji jumps
in and rescues him yuji takes on the
spirit but the spirit easily overpowers
him megami explains to yuji how it takes
cursed energy to exercise the spirit
yuji wonders why the spirit is after the
finger to which megumi says that the
spirit wants to eat it in order to get
stronger the curse seriously injured
megami to the point that he was forced
to dispel his shikigami leaving him
completely helpless if yuji had not
eaten sukuna's finger to gain access to
cursed energy in order to fight the
curse it's likely that both he and
megumi would not have survived the
encounter number 10. finger bearer
finger bearers are a type of special
grade cursed spirits that emerge from
cursed wombs spawned from secunda's
fingers they begin as cursed wombs where
they gestate until birth during this
period they can be seen by non-sorcerers
once born they can create an innate
domain a precursor to a domain expansion
that warps the dimensions of its
birthplace finger bearers possess the
normal abilities of a cursed spirit but
they are incredibly powerful due to
possessing one of tsukuna's fingers so
far they are shown to be intelligent
cursed spirits with a penchant for
cruelty and toying with their opponents
much like sukuna himself during the
mission to confirm and rescue any
possible survivors at the juvenile
detention center yuji and megami
encounter a finger bearer that was born
from the previously reported cursed womb
the spirit slices itadore's left hand
off before they could even react yuji
then attempts to buy time for megumi to
rescue nobara once megumi and nobara are
out of the center yuji switches with
sukuna the king of curses initially
attempts to cooperate with the finger
bearer but the cursed spirit attempts to
kill him only to get completely
overpowered sukuna is somewhat amused by
the special grade's efforts but in the
end he activates his domain expansion
malevolent shrine and exercises the
finger mirror taking his finger
afterward another finger bearer was
encountered by megumi in the domain of
the cursed spirit under yasuhashi bridge
after exercising the mole curse megami
is surprised to find the domain still
intact whereupon the finger bearer
emerges to confront him however the
finger bear proves to be several degrees
stronger than its counterpart in the
juvenile detention center thoroughly
overpowering megumi and breaking his
sword with only hishikigami saving him
from certain death nevertheless the
bearer knocks out megami temporarily
forcing him into a corner this leads
megami seriously considering a
last-ditch tactic only to scrap it in
favor of trying out an incomplete domain
expansion the curse is temporarily
overwhelmed by the combined attacks of
megumi and ishikigami but is ultimately
able to dispel the domain using a blast
of explosive cursed energy however this
proves to be a diversion as the unwary
finger bearer is stabbed by divine dog
exercising it and finally dispelling the
domain number 9. kichizu kachizu is a
cursed womb and the youngest brother of
choso and esso he and esso serve as
primary antagonist of the death painting
arc kachizzo appears much more like a
curse than his humanoid brothers he has
a small face on the upper part of his
head and a giant mouth just beneath it
khachizu was sent on an errant to
yasuhachi bridge to retrieve one of
sukuna's fingers once at the bridge
kichizu enters the cursed spirits
territory and encounters yuji nobara and
megumi kichizu gets into a fight with
yuji where kachizu tries to shoot blood
at yuji but fails as kachizu gets a hold
of yuji yuji twists himself out of the
way before kicking kichizu away kichizu
then proclaims that yuji is strong and
that this is not fun when eso takes
nobara out of the territory kichitsu
decides to head out as well with yuji
following closely behind when kitizu and
yuji exit the spirit's territory they
notice essos back and quickly apologize
for having esso become angry at them as
eso forces yuji and nobara to run
kichizu takes a shortcut and cuts the
two off he takes his chance to hit ut
with his blood when esso deactivates
their decay technique nabarro uses her
own body to harm the two brothers as
kachizza was distracted by this yuji
starts to attack him kichizu then gets
up and goes after nobara but nobara uses
black flash to wound kachizu when nobara
turns her back on kachizu kichizu tries
to kill her but nabarro uses hairpin on
kichizu to kill him number eight esso
eso pulls nabara out of the cursed
spirit's domain and tells her that she
may leave since the errand that the
brothers have doesn't involve killing
sorcerers as nabarro is confused about
what eso's errand is eso says that he
thought the sorcerers were sent to
retrieve sukuna's finger too when magumi
retrieves the finger esso senses that
the finger has exited the realm esther
decides to head over to retrieve the
finger with nabara following him nabarro
points out the weird way he is running
which esso says that he has a complex
about his back and that he will kill her
if she sees it esso uses his maximum
winking technique and starts to attack
nobara and yuji so then deactivates
decay and explains how yuji and nobara
will die he asks them if they wish to be
killed faster which nabarro responds by
using her resonance technique on herself
to inflict harm to the brothers esso
thinks about nabarro's technique and
that it won't be enough to kill him
before she dies when yuji and nobara
switch targets esso thinks about the
situation they are in and decides not to
deactivate his technique when kichizou
calls out esso he remembers what their
older brother told them and deactivates
this technique when yuji uses black
flash to blow off eso's arm esso thinks
about how yuji was able to do that even
though he had reinforced his arms with
cursed energy before yuji even landed
his attack eso then senses that kichizu
had died and apologizes to their older
brother for not saving him when a car
suddenly drives past them eso takes his
chance to get on the car and take a
hostage as the car drives away esso
plans to heal himself and to get revenge
on yuji and obara for killing his
brother as esso looks over to where
kichizu is he notices nobara and wonders
what she is doing as nabarro uses her
resonance technique on essa's severe arm
to inflict damage dasso esso falls off a
car and yuji takes this chance to
finally kill him number 7 joso jozo is
one of the cursed wombs and is ranked as
the special grade cursed material he's
incarnated into a human's body and now
looks like a human the death paintings
were considered harmful by the jujutsu
society and they were locked up in tokyo
high's secret warehouse for more than
150 years just so when his brothers
stayed there until konjaku's group
busted them out during the kyoto
goodwill event joseph mostly stayed at
kanjaku's base before the shibuya
incident he received a vision about the
death of his brothers after they were
wiped out by yuji and nobara he decided
to avenge them by killing yuji so he
joined the main forces of kanjaku during
the shibuya incident arc he fought gojo
along with other curses but it was
pretty obvious that they stood no chance
against him after gojo finally got
sealed into the prison realm the spirits
could finally make a move and joseph
started searching for yuji joseph found
him rather quickly and their battle
started it was a one-sided fight for the
most part with joso being visibly
stronger than yuji yuji got wounded
multiple times during their fight and
joseph was about to murder him but
suddenly he blanked out he had a vision
about yuji being his brother josue
didn't know what was happening and he
decided to run away and think about it
he left yuji there to collect himself
and move on later on when chozo finally
cleared his mind and figured out that he
should protect yuji as his brother he
joined the frey against kenjaku sadly he
and the rest of the sorceress couldn't
do anything against the ancient sorcerer
after the enemies run away chosu stays
on the spot with yuji yuji says that
they can't return anywhere as he killed
too many people including joseph's
brothers the latter forgave yuji and
advised him to keep going even though
joseph was a curse he showed many human
characteristics like his love for his
brothers and also siding with yuji and
turning on other curses in order to
protect him he's a character that many
fans will grow to like in the future
number six hanomy at a first glance
hanumi does not appear as intimidating
or as strong as some of the other curses
but appearances can be deceiving hotomy
is easily one of the strongest curses in
the series and was able to go toe-to-toe
with multiple jujutsu sorcerers at once
hanami is the type of spirit who cares
for the planet and hates humans that
have been abusing it for thousands of
years he wishes to kill humans in order
to sacrifice them so they can be sages
to a cleaner world controlled by spirits
that will respect the earth hanumi is
one of the special grade curses with an
incredibly durable body an innate
technique that controls plants and an
uncanny ability to hide his presence he
was able to take gojo by surprise and
momentarily take advantage of yuji's
vulnerability using his flower field and
a wooden monster in order to rescue jogo
this was achievable due to a combination
of hanemi's high intellect as a curse as
well as his escaping abilities and
hidden presence gojo himself commends
hanami's ability to run away able to
evade the 6i's strong perception and
even claims to find tony far more
threatening than the straightforward
jogo during the kyoto goodwill event
hanami invades the school along with his
allies he heads over to where the
students are fighting and encounters
toge hanami then fights toge until they
come across megumi and noritoshi he then
tries to attack the three but toge
restrains him using cursed speech the
group then attacks him but is unable to
do any significant damage he is then
sent flying when toga uses the last of
his strength but doesn't get sent far
maki shows up and hanemi fights against
her and megumi as honoree starts to get
the upper hand yuji and toto show up to
rescue the two he then fights yuji and
gets injured when yuji lands a black
flash on him hanomi continues to fight
against the two but is repeatedly harmed
by their attacks he is pushed into a
corner and attempts to steal the life
energy from nearby plants but he is
stopped when gojo finally arrives he is
then hit by gojo's hollow purple
technique and is heavily wounded however
he's able to escape barely clinging to
his life number 5. dagon dagon is a
special great cursed spirit with massive
amounts of cursed energy and the ability
to manipulate water while in his weaker
cursed womb form dagon can easily
dispatch numerous non-sorcerers simply
by devouring them he can cast his own
domain and manifest a vast amount of
water dagon in his fully released form
is far more powerful and he can rival
the strength of his special great allies
his strength was high enough to go
toe-to-toe with zen and family head
naobirdo zenon using his domain daggen
can overpower a group of high-ranking
jujutsu sorcerers naoto maki nanami and
megumi together could not defeat dagen
inside his domain despite working
together when toji enters the domain
dagon thinks about hitoji doesn't have
any cursed energy and attacks with the
weak shikigami tojo easily takes care of
the shikigami and attacks dagon causing
him to wonder about the power that toji
has dagen attacks with more shikigami
but again tojo easily dispatches them he
tries to escape but naobito blocks his
path and toji takes his chance to attack
and exercise dagon number 4. mojito
mojito is one of the primary antagonists
of the jujutsu kaizen series he is a
cursed spirit allied with pseudo-ghetto
his group's ultimate goal is the
eradication of humanity and ultimately
replacing the population with cursed
spirits mojito is a sadistic immature
cursed spirit who enjoys toying with
human emotions he believes he was born
from human transgression and considers
himself the very manifestation of humans
hatred for each other as such majido
believes that humans should be
extinguished and her spirits should rule
in their place he is an unregistered
special great cursed spirit that
eclipses the power of at least three of
cicuna's fingers he is younger than jojo
and as a result is less experienced and
not as powerful despite this mojito is
far above what a special great cursed
spirit would normally be he has very
high intelligence and extremely
dangerous curse techniques mojito has
incredible development potential as on
multiple instances he has developed in
the middle of a battle in episode 9 it
is revealed that some high schoolers
were killed by mojito in order to garner
favor with a boy named june pay whom
they had bullied mojito it turns out
killed the three kids by holding a hand
to their heads instantly causing them to
distort and explode this is the first
instance in which viewers witness mojito
exhibiting his signature technique
called idol transfiguration later mojito
encounters gentonomy and the two start
their fight eventually nanami escapes by
bearing mojito and the rubble this is in
my opinion one of the most interesting
fights in the anime so far as it is the
first time we got to see naomi's and
mojito's unique powers he later shows up
during the fight between yuji and jun
pay mojito restrains yuji using his
abilities to transform june pay mijito
laughs after jinpe dies at which point
yuji punches him he notices that there
is something different about that bunch
and realizes that yuji can naturally
injure him mojito then takes on yuji and
manages to force him into the courtyard
outside as the two fight anatomy shows
up and tries to assist yuji mojito after
being attacked by both sorcerers at the
same time uses his domain expansion to
trap nanome and leaves it to dory
outside of it as he prepares to kill him
yuji forcibly enters his territory as
sucuna and heavily enters mojito who
manages to escape just in time mikito
then recovers in the sewer and thinks
about how powerful sukuna is and how he
will kill yuji next number 3 jogo jogo
is an immensely powerful cursed spirit
he is the most powerful of kanjaki's
group and arguably the most powerful
true curse spirit in the series his
might surpasses the strongest death
painting and is only surpassed by
vengeful cursed spirits like sukuna and
special great sorcerers like gojo with
his immensely dangerous curse technique
and his massive cursed energy joko is
strong enough to be acknowledged by
sukuna himself his power is equal to
eight or nine sakuna fingers jogo has
immense pride as a cursed spirit and has
a passionate hatred for humans it is his
belief that cursed spirits are the true
form of humanity as they represent the
pure truths of life such as hatred while
normal humans fake so many positive
emotions we see jogo for the first time
along with hanami and dagon at a
restaurant during the meeting jogo
reveals that they plan to destroy all
the humans joko also asks a guru how to
defeat the sorcerers which the guru
tells them that they first need to seal
gojo and then they need sukuna on their
side as djogo suggests that they just go
and kill gojo suguru tells him that
they're not capable of doing that and
that they will need a specific seal to
trap him later joko goes on his own to
attack gojo when he is alone joko throws
multiple attacks at gojo but is shocked
when he is revealed to be unharmed as
joko refuses to accept this gojo takes
the chance to land multiple blows on him
he is then sent flying when gojo simply
kicks him jogo remembers how suguru told
him that he would die if he decides to
drag gojo into his domain jogo's then
shocked when gojo is completely fine and
none of his attacks seem to inflict any
damage onto him he suddenly gets trapped
by gojo's domain as he notices that he
is now capable of seeing and feeling
everything gojo grabs him and explains
how his technique works he is eventually
spared by gojo since he has questions
for him as gojo starts to ask questions
joko is saved by hanami he is then
brought to dagen's domain where suguru
explains they will have to deal with
gojo at another time and place even
though jogo lost against gojo he
demonstrated amazing raw power and his
domain technique would likely have
allowed him to defeat almost any other
sorcerer draft inside therefore we
consider him one of the strongest curses
in the entire show number two cursed
rika rika orimoto was just an ordinary
girl at the very start of the manga but
things took an outrageous turn for her
not only did she lose her appearance as
a woman but she also converted it into
an ugly looking curse even after this
drastic change in her whole appearance
one thing that remained constant was her
love for yuda you can call her naive but
she is clear on whom she wants to
protect rika is one of the essential
characters in the manga she as the
full-time partner of yuda plays a
significant role in developing his
personality she saved yuda's life on
several occasions when he tried to
commit suicide she came in his way and
stopped him rika also played a vital
role in defeating ghetto if she had
fallen into ghetto's hand it would have
been awful for the jujutsu sorcerers
because according to ghetto she was the
queen of curses on the 24th of december
to execute his plan and win the war
ghetto invaded the college his primary
goal was to eliminate yudah and get rika
on his side during their encounter yuda
summons rika and fights against ghetto
and the cursed spirits around them yuna
asks rika to grab his friend and escort
them to a safer location to which rika
readily agrees rika and ghetto then face
off with each other head to head when
ghetto sees the immense display of power
by rika as she easily crushes and
dismantles his cursed spirits his desire
to acquire rika becomes even more
significant ghetto then reduces the
distance between them and converts the
battle into close combat in which he
easily overpowers rika however being in
a close quarters fight made ghetto
reveal all his fighting styles in front
of yuda who then uses this revelation as
an advantage and manages to push ghetto
into a corner however the fight doesn't
end here as ghetto has one more trick up
his sleeve he then to win uses his
maximum uzumaki technique to its limit
which is combining all 4 000 curses he
has in his possession to do a one-hit
attack yuda at this point gives up and
thanks rika for always protecting him
and then kisses her as a token of
goodbye however this kiss excites rika
and breaks all of the cursed limits on
her rika then unlocked the true
potential that enabled her to use a
powerful blast which annihilated all
ghettos cursed spirits including ghetto
himself there is no way that any of the
previously mentioned curses would have
even come close to defeating rika and
that's why she definitely deserves a
second place on our list number one
sukuna ryoman sukuna is a mighty cursed
spirit known as the undisputed king of
curses he is the strongest curse to ever
walk the face of the earth according to
the legend during the golden age of jiu
jitsu over a thousand years ago sukuna
was an imaginary demon though in truth
he was a human sorcerer and other
sorcerers gave their all to defeat him
after his death he became a cursed
spirit and his curse was too strong for
his body to be fully destroyed
henceforth his remains of 20
indestructible fingers preserved in
grave wax traverse the ages as cursed
objects ever growing in power one of
cicuna's fingers was kept in an outdoor
thermometer box at tsukisaba high school
the school's occult club had taken the
finger from the box and had tried to
remove the seal placed on it once they
had taken the seal of the finger off
other curse spirits attacked the club
members as yuji and megumi came in to
save the club members yuji eats the
finger in order to fight off the cursed
spirits which resulted in yuji sharing
his body with sukuna sukuna is selfish
cold-hearted immortal and exceptionally
sadistic due to his immense power he
rarely cares about the consequences of
his actions even if these affect his
host yu-gi-oh todori in fact he
frequently taunts and insults yuji
calling him a brat and even laughing at
or enjoying yuji's despair on multiple
occasions although yuji is the perfect
vessel for sukuna's soul tsukuna still
manages to occasionally wrestle control
from yuji and take advantage of his
freedom as the most powerful cursed
spirit in the entire series sukuna
possesses vast amounts of cursed energy
his presence was felt throughout shibuya
once he was awakened his cursed energy
is similar to satoru gojo in its
immensity but different in its
overwhelmingly evil nature he soon went
on to overwhelm and defeat jojo the most
powerful cursed spirit in ghetto's group
even gojo acknowledged sekuna's strength
stating that fighting him would be tough
in every single appearance sukunna has
proved that he is by far the strongest
cursed spirit ever he seriously injured
mojito and angered defeated jogo without
much trouble and even managed to defeat
maharaga something no user of the ten
shadows technique and even a member of
the gojo family had done his strength is
so great that mojito and jogo were
convinced that sekuna's revival would
ensure their success sukuna strength is
only rivaled by other special grades
like yuda and gojo click on this video
to see more content like this